okay he is in the news room at the
Washington Post he is managing editor of
the newspaper and he is the author of
the new book that looks at Afghanistan
in that region of the world
the rise of fundamentalist Islam and
also the rise of terrorism in that
region of the world it's called ghost
wars the secret history of the CIA
Afghanistan and bin Laden from the
Soviet invasion to September 10th 2001
mr. Coll thanks very much for being with
us thanks for having me well I know this
is difficult with all the pages you
spent on this but if you could
characterize the 25 years that you write
about both from the
intelligence-gathering perspective and
the will of national leaders how would
you do that
well I think you have to divide it into
three phases first is the period from
the time that the Soviets moved into
Afghanistan in 1979 until the time they
left that's a fairly well-known chapter
in the CIA's history in which the CIA
collaborated with Pakistani and Saudi
intelligence on a secret and ultimately
quite expensive program designed to
boost the Mujahideen rebels and expel
Soviet forces that program was
successful but along the way it fuelled
and created and and empowered radical
Islamist networks that then flourished
long after we had lost interest in
Afghanistan I think the second part of
the story begins when the Soviets leave
and runs through about 1997 1998 and
there the story is one of American
withdrawal we lost interest in
Afghanistan we saw no interests there
and so we stood aside as as the country
fell apart as a humanitarian crisis
deepened and as the Taliban rose to
power and we were slow to recognize the
Taliban as a dangerous force both in the
region and beyond and we really just
pulled out and then the third fit and
final phase of the story is the part
that begins really in 1998 which is
about the return of the CIA to
Afghanistan this time to try to capture
kill or disrupt in Laden before he could
strike American targets and this is a
story that's not very well known in the
United States but it's a very important
part of the antecedents of the September
11th attacks
it's essentially it's a story of a very
tightly held secret series of operations
that ultimately were unsuccessful but
the details of them signal thus mixed
approaches that the United States had to
the bin Laden problem before 9/11 ken
can you talk about your sources for this
I can't really discuss it I what I
explained in the book is that the book
is is a work of journalism it's based
primarily on interviews I conducted
about 200 interviews not only with
American sources but also with Afghan
Pakistani and Saudi sources many of the
interviews were conducted on the record
those are footnoted explicitly in the
book a number of the other interviews
were not conducted in on ground rules
that allow me to name the sources and
the book is though I think very
carefully footnoted one of my goals was
to try to make this history as
transparent as I could not only for
Americans to examine and assess for
themselves but also for Afghans whose
own history important strands of their
own history has been long hidden from
them because they involved the
activities of a several intelligence
services the Americans but perhaps more
importantly the Pakistanis and the
Saudis have you been asked to testify
before the 9/11 Commission and if you
were would you do it I have not been
asked and I don't think that that would
be an appropriate role for me as a
journalist can you answer that the
difficult question could 9/11 have been
prevented I think it's difficult to boil
a history like this down to that
question though I recognize the
temptation and indulge in it myself I
think there are lots of moments along
the road where it's possible to look
back and say what if if we had picked up
this thread if we had made this decision
in a different way would 9/11 have
unfolded the way it did and I think
those are legitimate discussions to hold
when I look back at some of those
episodes though I think that it's safe
to say that al-qaeda and the terrorist
threat that it continues to present the
United States and to the Western world
almost certainly would have continued to
metastasize the way that it did
would still be a threat today I think
the more intriguing what-if question if
you want to in indulge in that
discussion is would the specific attacks
that were carried out on September 11th
with their unique destructive power and
their unique shocking violence could
those specific attacks have been
prevented and there I think there are
some what-ifs that that people can
discuss and probably will for many years
I know that George Tenet was up on
Capitol Hill yesterday and talking a lot
about the continuation of threat and
also defending some of the intelligence
during our conversation with you from
time to time I want to show you some of
his assessments of where we are now and
have you react based on on your
reporting and investigation but before
we get to calls if you would could you
summarize briefly the excerpt that
appeared in the Sunday paper about the
as you call it secret hunt that
unraveled at the last minute when it
looked as though the US and intelligence
agencies were close to getting bin Laden
yes this is the part of the story we
were talking about earlier and it really
begins early in 1998 when the CIA
operating out of its Islamabad station
put a group of paid agents into the
field for the purpose of attempting to
locate and possibly to kidnap Osama bin
Laden who was then living in on a farm
near Kandahar and they developed a very
specific plan to raid this farm in the
middle of the night pull bin Laden out
of his bed take him to a cave where they
were gonna hold him for thirty days and
try to seek an indictment so that they
could try him in a courtroom either in
the United States or possibly in Saudi
Arabia or Egypt this was the first in a
series of plans of this character to try
to get bin Laden and it was sent up the
chain of command and it was ultimately
turned down and was judged to be
unworkable there were fears that it that
there would be a lot of innocent deaths
along the way and that ultimately the
attackers simply wouldn't succeed after
that there were several other similar
kinds of episodes that did come closer
to fruition I'll just briefly mention a
couple one
in the early part of 1999 involved this
same group of agents tracking bin Laden
to a hunting camp in the southern Afghan
deserts where they felt that they had
him spotted and they they put a GPS
beacon on the ground and the agency set
satellites up to confirm that this was a
hunting camp they saw an airplane there
with some tail numbers that they traced
the United Arab Emirates an important
oil-producing ally the United States and
this episode went on for about two weeks
and ultimately the White House and the
highest levels of the CIA had a very
intensive discussion about whether to
attack with crude and cruise missiles
and the hope that they would kill bin
Laden and once again ultimately they
decided that the risks were too great
the evidence was too uncertain and
decided not to act and one of the
patterns that develops as these episodes
unfold one after another is that the
officers on the ground mainly with the
CIA sometimes with other agencies begin
to get frustrated they they think that
their commanders aren't taking the
threat seriously enough and are not
willing to bear risks in the pursuit of
bin Laden yeah some in fact who we're
willing to have you print their name
their frustration was so great let's go
to some calls for you and hear what
people have to say let's begin with a
call from San Francisco go ahead please
good morning how are you
there's a point in your book that you
were discussing on NPR the other day
where they're making a lot of decisions
about bin Laden and it rises when when
all the impeachment stuff starts with
Clinton and you sort of allude to the
fact that you feel that it was a
distraction for the administration that
the impeachment thing was going on in
terms of the whole you know and you
connected to the bin Laden thing do you
know which yes I remember that that
segment of the interview and of course
the thing to remember is that the Africa
embassy bombings which was the first
time that bin Laden really emerged as a
direct threat to the United States with
a proven now capability of killing
Americans that occurred in August early
August of nine
298 and you'll recall that about ten
days later President Clinton went on
national television to admit for the
first time under the pressure of some
grand jury testimony the nature of his
relationship with Monica Lewinsky and
the the sort of crisis and the hysteria
that unfolded surrounding the
impeachment process really began
simultaneously with the recognition that
bin Laden was a direct threat to the
United States the impeachment crisis of
course runs from August of 98 into the
early months of 1999 and that is the
time when the CIA is first sort of
dispatched to try to disrupt kill or
capture bin Laden and that is when the
president is presented with the first in
a series of decisions about what kind of
risks he's prepared to take to get it to
get after bin Laden I just want to make
clear as I think I did in the other
interview that the president and his
senior national security aides
emphatically say to this day that the
impeachment crisis was not a distraction
that the president was able to separate
his role as commander-in-chief from the
the personal and political problems that
he faced in the Lewinsky matter but I
think that at a minimum any reasonable
reading of the history of this period
especially with the benefit of hindsight
has to acknowledge that the presidency
itself whatever the president's ability
to separate these things
the president's presidency itself was
very badly weakened during this time
there was a hostile Republican Congress
a special prosecutor was still seeking
indictments or exploring their
possibility and there was an impeachment
proceeding under the way for the first
time in a hundred years
so just realistically the political
context in which the bin Laden problem
unfolded was one in which the president
was I think you know pretty severely
constrained mr. crawle in a related
question assuming both candidates would
have would be well briefed on the nature
of the al Qaeda threat during the 2000
campaign why was it not a topic that was
more more pointedly debated and brought
to the attention of the American
you know we were all unaware of the
seriousness of the bin Laden threat and
that includes the media includes you
know the Washington Post and a lot of
other major institutions in this country
nobody really understood the potential
of bin Laden to wreak the kind of havoc
that he did in the United States
apart from small groups of professionals
inside the national security bureaucracy
whose job it was to get up every morning
and work on this problem and so there
was really not a political debate about
the issues that have so dominated the
country's affairs since September 11th
and neither candidate chose to run on
national security issues you had a vice
president who had been involved in a lot
of this and who understood it pretty
well I think factually and
intellectually but the campaign was run
primarily in other spheres mainly
domestic issues and the country believed
that it was at peace it was coming off
one of the most prosperous runs in its
recent economic history it seemed its
ideas seemed ascendant in the world and
the idea that there was some
transforming terrorist threat that was
so severe that it was going to change
the way Americans saw themselves in the
world they lived in that just seemed
unlikely in 2000 Pittsburgh you're on
too steep call hi yes thank you for
taking my call I have not read your book
however I do look forward to reading it
after listening to your discussion two
things I wanted to ask you first
following up with the comment that you
just made about the 2000 election and
the fact that the Clinton administration
and Al Gore in you the potential of bin
Laden and the al Qaeda the al Qaeda
threat you know we had already been
experiencing terrorist actions on a
smaller scale compared to 9/11 of course
with the USS Cole in the you know World
Trade Center earlier in the 90s and
I guess the feeling I have is that with
this race that's starting now for the
2004 election that again the American
public is being asked to put their head
in the sand and you know if we will it
away then it won't be that that we are
basically a real threat or real target
before these terrorist threats and it's
you know building and getting worse and
it's almost as though people don't want
to acknowledge that because it is it is
very frightening but my question I had
for you was with regard to the the the
weapons of mass destructions and the
Iraq war and the fact that so much
intelligence had been gathered for so
long that catalogued in great detail the
kinds of weapons and chemical and
biological weapons that that the Saddam
Hussein regime had control of and that
those were discussed at length at the UN
meetings and and detailed and that when
Hans Blix
and the inspectors were in there call
our tigers you long we have a lot of
callers on a lot of sorry and and so at
this point that you know we've been in
there and haven't discovered these vast
quantities of of weapons the fact that
it's being dismissed as as non real or
non realistic or faulty intelligence
disturbs me because I find it hard to
believe that that much could be
collected and it be so wrong and I'd
like to know what your thoughts are
Thanks
well that's a completely different
subject from from what I've spent a lot
of time reporting on but I do have my
impression is based on what's been
disclosed so far that to the extent that
there's a theory about why we didn't
find anything it involves the sort of
internal collapse of Saddam Hussein's
regime
in the last few years before the
American invasion and the fact that he
was bluffing his neighbors and his own
scientists were probably bluffing him
about what they were up to and so there
was this sort of mutually reinforcing
series of deceptions and shell games and
and some of it involving personal
corruption that created the misleading
impression for everybody who was trying
to collect evidence about it that's
that's my best sense of it so far I
think we got a lot to learn let me take
it from the specific question about
intelligence on WMD in Iraq to the
larger examination of the intelligence
process by this country here's a about
thirty seconds from George Tenet
yesterday on Capitol Hill specifically
talking about information gathering and
analysis with Senator Dick Durbin of
Illinois we're not perfect but we're
pretty damn good at what we do and we
care as much as you do about Iraq and
whether we were right or wrong and we're
gonna work through it in a way where we
tell the truth was to whether we were
right or wrong but at the end of the day
we followed this for eight nine ten
years we had deep concerns about the
history the deceit what he didn't give
the UN and as I said my Georgetown
speech
we worked hard after 1998 to resuscitate
sources and the record was mixed and we
made judgments on a narrower band of
data this is a tough business it's call
well you know this is a subject with a
long history the intelligence community
often has to make informed guesses about
profoundly important questions on the
basis of fragmentary data and there's a
record of misses as well as successes
going back to the Cold War period where
we overestimated Soviet capabilities in
a number of phases it is a tough
business the evidence is hard to work
with and yet policymakers demand
certainty or certainly prefer it where
it's available I think the biggest
question that the CIA internally is
going to review as a result of this
failed analysis it seems in Iraq is
whether the process was as sound as it
should have been was descent promoted as
part of the process was was the evidence
really carefully reviewed for its
credibility were where the political
motivations of sources scrubbed out of
the process was there a was there a
really a free debate about the facts or
was there a political context that
pushed people to certain conclusions you
know that's what the American system the
American people I think expect of the
intelligence process is that it's clean
and that it's apolitical and that is
driven by the best people and the best
available evidence and I think a lot of
the review and the Iraq case will be
about those issues now to get you back
to your story if you take those same
sets of questions and parameters and
apply them to the analysis of the
information about the Taliban and
al-qaeda what kind of conclusions can
you draw interesting question first on
the subject of the Taliban I think
everybody looking back through the
window of 9/11 most people would agree
that one of the mistakes of American
policy this is more of a policy area
than an impure intelligence area was the
failure to recognize the Taliban as part
of the problem American policy between
1998 and 2001 tended to approach bin
Laden in isolation didn't see him in his
Afghan context didn't regard the Taliban
as a threat to the United States or to
its interests didn't move to examine the
networks of support that the Taliban
thrived on in Pakistani intelligence in
the Persian Gulf these proselytising
networks and others that have now
emerged as such a sort of central part
of our of our response to the events of
September 11th none of that was on the
table
bin Laden wasn't was seen in isolation
and the CIA and others that were asked
to go after him
were asked to threat a very small needle
the United States wasn't prepared to
deal with Afghanistan it's humanitarian
crises its political crises and all of
the the world that made bin Laden so
able to thrive
in the Afghan sanctuary I think that is
a strategic error in retrospect Fells
Point Maryland received call a good
morning Susan you're very charming um
mr. Cole it's quite funny that you were
on this morning I was just been reading
Michael Moore's book and I meant the
chapter where he's talking about Valmai
calluses and hamid karzai
who are former staffers of Unocal and i
wanted to know if you address the
Caspian Sea gas pipeline in your book
and also whether you delved into the
question of the heroin problem and the
poppies in Afghanistan yes both of those
are subjects of the narrative and they
are important threads in the case of
Unocal as you recall this was a los
angeles-based American oil company that
intended to build a gas pipeline from
Turkmenistan and near the Caspian Sea
all the way across Afghanistan to
Pakistan and in order to build this
pipeline they needed peace in
Afghanistan and so they began to
negotiate with the Taliban and to some
extent the reference were supported by
the State Department and and the Clinton
administration which thought maybe this
pipeline would provide a way for Afghans
to settle their differences and create
jobs and so forth I think in retrospect
it's a very tawdry episode it involved
the distortion of the meaning of
American diplomacy American power and it
at least created the impression at a
minimum you would say it created the
impression in the region that all of the
United States policy in Afghanistan was
tied up with a commercial agenda at a
time when Afghans were suffering one of
the deepest humanitarian crises in the
world next is Palm Bay Florida you're on
the air um I have two quick questions
though the first one considering that in
five to ten years Holland Germany and
France will become majority majority
Muslim it's this terrorism is a blip in
time or in your opinion does this go
back to 700 AD when the Prophet warrior
Prophet Muhammad
his teachings and writings that we
should control the world and the second
one is the Democratic congressman I
can't remember his name that was
fighting the Mujahideen and was he the
father of the CIA plan to go in and help
boat or Russia thank you take the second
one first this is Charlie Wilson I
suspect you're referring to he was a
conservative congressman from Texas in
the 1980s who was singularly responsible
for increasing the amount of money that
Congress secretly appropriated to
support the Afghan which Hadean rebels
in the 1980s I you know some people
regard him as the father of the program
other people think that he was an
important but you know important part of
a much broader array I attended the
latter view he he certainly is a
colorful figure whom who walked across
the stage in the 80s as to your first
question you know I'm not much of a
theorist about these kinds of things but
it's sort of obvious that Islam and
Christendom have lived sort of more in
peace than at war over a thousand years
and yet this version of Islamic theology
that bin Laden espouses which denies the
pluralism that generally characterizes
Islam's relations in the world it is is
a rising minority sect in the Sunni
Islamic world and I think it's going to
be some of the United States will
confront for decades pleasant valley
california is next and you're on the air
for steve call go ahead caller I just
let Valley New York it is this
matter-of-fact okay I'm sorry about that
yes I haven't read the book it's on the
first-time caller
we've established that Clinton had a
problem on his last year in office and
he was unable to do anything in
Afghanistan because of this problem
given that fact once we we got into the
Afghanistan conflict one of the problems
we have with this administration is
unfounded unfunded mandates
once the government had fallen we did
not have a funded central government and
since that problem exists the opium
problem in Afghanistan has been
established and we still do not have a
strong central government I'd like to
have your opinion as to how we could
effectuate a remedy to this problem
given the problem we have now with a the
end of the administration yes well it
almost certainly take patience and care
because there's there was very little
capacity in Afghanistan that you would
or anyone else would recognize as a
government there you know there's an
effort now gradually to build that
capacity up and I think initially in the
United States was slow to recognize the
importance of that project in sustaining
a stable future for for Afghanistan I
think now there's a greater recognition
that slowly project-by-project
season-by-season a central democratic
Afghan government is it's going to have
to be the vessel into which the United
States and other countries pour their
support because it's really only by that
path that you can sustain the progress
that's been created since September
since the fall of the Taliban in
December of 2001 more from a CIA
director George Tenet yesterday on
Capitol Hill
although gaps in our understanding
remain we see al Qaeda's program to
produce anthrax as one of the most
immediate terrorist CBRN threat CBR and
threats that we are likely to face okay
that continues to pursue its strategic
goal of obtaining a nuclear capability
it remains interested in dirty bombs
terrorist documents contain accurate
views of how much how such weapons would
be used mr. crawle in your telling of
the tale when did Al Qaida and
like-minded groups move from thinking
about using conventional means of
warfare to these more diabolical
it means aimed at civilian populations
the first hard evidence of that surfaces
in 1996 when a defector in bin Laden's
inner circle he was then living in Sudan
walked out he had some money problems
with the group and he essentially
defected to the United
States and he provided extensive and
credible testimony about the discussions
inside bin Laden's inner circle and he
described efforts at that time 1995-1996
they've been Laden and undertaken to
purchase uranium and to start discussing
the possibilities of unconventional
weapons now his interest and those
things may have dated even before that
but that's I think pretty solid evidence
of when he first was active in this area
Clinton Maryland
good morning caller alright we're gonna
move on Ogden Utah you're on the air yes
yes I had a question with the Bush
administration if there's rolling stones
made a tie between bin Laden family and
the Bush administration way back in the
89 90s um Bush the first Bush was
director of CIA went from director said
it's a vice president was Reagan for one
term went back to director of CIA and
then became president now if this guy
who's director of CIA and leader of all
our secret information do you think that
because they found Hussein before
election time for campaign type to sway
Bush's voters do you think they'll find
bin Laden before election to sway again
the voters the bush will be reelected
just one thing you President George Bush
HW Bush Bush 41 as they call him was
director of the CIA briefly in the
mid-1970s then he of course served two
terms as vice president and then
succeeded the presidency the you know
the hunt for bin Laden as you've seen in
the news is underway again this spring
my my sense just from talking to people
around town is that the people involved
in it think that they're closer to
getting him than they've been for a
while whether they're in fact closer
they're not even 100% certain I don't I
think that the one aspect of this that
most people involved are developing some
sense of confidence about is that they
they kind of have a
the region that he's in the trouble is
that unlike Saddam Hussein this where
Saddam Hussein was hiding this region is
much more difficult to operate in the
the terrain is is difficult the local
population is uniformly hostile and the
presence of American and Pakistani
forces is is much thinner than it was in
the in the area where Saddam was hiding
so very hard to forecast how this is
going to turn out this year next call is
from Windham Connecticut welcome to
c-span good morning mr. Kaul I've been a
Monday Monday Morning Quarterback since
the Depression years and what people
fail to realize is the greatest threat
to society today and it's always has
been since my early childhood is
communism the greatest manipulator on
the face of the world and why don't we
investigate that especially in the
educational system as well as the
political system communism is not dead
and they dug in real deep thank you very
much thanks for your comment next is
Brooklyn New York hello yes sir you're
on the air oh hi didn't even hear it
come through yeah and I was listening to
you I have a couple of well actually one
basic question on acceptance and
pluralistic religious societies I've
noticed over historically that in
Islamic pluralistic religious societies
that for the most part pluralism is
allowed to exist in situations where
judeo-christian values they're held in a
subservient a very weak position and in
judeo-christian pluralistic societies
expected that in having more equal
footing so my question to you but the
Wiis Americans or even people who were
judeo-christian why we should even
remotely accept Islamic view of
pluralism and why we should even put up
with it I mean this leads to a whole lot
of value system space with Islamism
begin with because they refuse to accept
on the whole what others believe in and
that's my question to you
well I'm not sure that I would accept
that characterization of Islamic
pluralism but I really don't know enough
about it to know exactly what you're
referring to but I do think that your
question contains an important point
which applies to the kind of theology
that bin Laden now promotes and which
has also been present in the past in in
some radical Christian doctrines which
is the question of what does the
religion make of a non-believer and that
one of the aspects of bin Laden's
violence is his fervent conviction that
non-believers civilians military anyone
are so far outside God's community and
such a threat to God's community that
they should be destroyed and that is a
essentially a you know sort of a
playbook for for mass casualties and
that aspect of intolerance is the direct
threat that is contained in this
theology everything else is essentially
a form of argument in your newspaper
this morning you have a quote from Moore
testimony by the intelligence chiefs
yesterday and I'd like to have you
incorporate this into your explanation
our understanding of how much how large
the threat might be in the future
despite recent reforms terrorist
organizations draw from societies with
poor or failing economies ineffective
governments and inadequate education
systems and demographic bubbles of young
people further burden governments and
economies and these countries have a
high proportion of population under the
age of 15 Saudi Arabia 43% Iraq 41
Pakistan 39 Egypt 34% under the age of
15
Algeria 33 in Iran 29 yeah these
demographic statistics are continually
cycling through these new sorts of
assessments and they are disturbing I'm
not really sure how important they are
as a kind of a cause of the crisis
because they've been around for a long
while but there's certainly a factor I
think what was what was particularly
interesting about the testimony
yesterday in this area was the portrait
of what's happened to al-qaeda as a
organization and as a
since September 11th and I I from my own
sense of things endorsed what what the
DCI said which is that the headquarters
group the the organization that carried
out the September 11th attacks it's been
substantially disrupted and and and even
in in substantial part dismantled but
that's just to think that that's the end
of the story is to misunderstand what it
was in the first place
al-qaeda was a sort of a series of
concentric circles that ultimately
reached out to a lot of regional groups
Chechens Indonesia and Filipinos North
Africans and others and those groups
thrive in the kinds of broken societies
that you refer to that are recruiting in
societies that are still subject to
radicalization because of the lack of
opportunity despotic government's whole
series of other issues and and so the
the important point is the idea that
these groups have been infected which
was the word that Tennant used by the by
the sheer spectacular ambitions that al
Qaeda displayed on September 11th that
they themselves now have grand ideas
about what it's possible to do to to
attract attention to strike the United
States to rattle the world and and that
has distributed this ambition quite
broadly around around these regional
groups in fact let's just let here the
director of Central Intelligence say
that in his own words this is Gregory so
far I've talked to you about al Qaeda
but it's not the limit of the terrorist
threat worldwide they've infected others
with its ideology which depicts the
United States as Islam's greatest foe
the steady growth of the sama bin
Laden's anti-american sentiment through
the wider Sunni extremist movement and
the broad dissemination of Al Qaeda's
destructive expertise ensure that a
serious threat will remain for the
foreseeable future
with or without al Qaeda in the picture
we're talking with Steve collies in the
newsroom scuse me of the Washington Post
this morning he is the author of the new
book available from penguin called ghost
wars it details the 25-year history
between the West
the United States and allies and the
developing terrorist threat in
Afghanistan and the region next call for
him is from Cape on bridge West Virginia
good morning
it allows you to get through and talk to
you both my issues are mainly regarding
what your book deals with is that I feel
we were let down a lot by our security
agencies in the 9/11 attack you know
from what I can gather from things that
I've read and seen we were told as early
as the mid nineties you know by like the
Philippine government that al Qaeda
wanted to fly a plane into the trade
center there are other governments that
has uncovered items that then they told
listen you know where I get particularly
bothered with that as when I hear
Condoleezza Rice what she said you know
how could we have ever known yada yada
yada you know that that that makes me
wonder also in 2000 I'll move up forward
and just leave it in 2000 of course we
had the field officer of the FBI and
Phoenix saying hey there's look at these
guys they're learning to fly planes and
then and then in Minnesota I believe in
August
Zacarias Moussaoui was if not arrested
brought in for questioning and the FBI
was unable to get into his laptop you
know maybe maybe now with with the
Patriot Act they would I'm not saying
that I'm war against the Patriot Act but
you know I really feel like we were let
down and I hope now that we have
homeland security our different security
branches will talk to each other a lot
better and then I'll finish with you
know I'm never a conspiracy theorist
kind of guy but when you see that
videotape of Bush at the elementary
school in Florida during when the 9/11
attacks actually happened and you see
his reaction it's a little scary thank
you thank you for the call
on the interaction between our security
branches yes I you know
it's if you if you talk to the people
who were living this in those years 99
2000 2001 even the two prominent
counterterrorism analysts at the Clinton
White House Dan Benjamin and Stephen
Simon who together written a important
book about all of this they they tend to
express their greatest dismay in
retrospect about the FBI that's their
point of view there's a lot of distance
between the White House and the FBI they
said the FBI was was not very well
organized to deal with the al Qaeda
threat it wasn't very communicative
you know equally there's there's
evidence on the record of avoidable
errors that the CIA's counter-terrorist
operation made in failing to watchlist a
couple of the ultimate 9/11 hijackers
who had been identified and surveyed at
a meeting with Islamic militants so
there's a lot of little bits and pieces
a lot of what-ifs that that are
available and will continue to be
debated should be debated certainly the
organization and the government in these
ways has changed dramatically since
September 11th and and so the whole
structure that was in place before has
been changed and also more notably it's
been heavily funded in comparison to the
level of resources that had had before
September 11th mr. Carlos you know
there's new tapes out that have been
played on the Arab aljazeera Network and
they have been confirmed by the CIA to
have been made by the the man is always
described as Osama bin Laden's top loose
lieutenant dr. Ayman al-zawahiri would
you talk a little bit about how the two
came together and how the two play off
one another yeah it's a very interesting
subject in some ways they're quite
different men and in other ways they're
they're quite similar in the context
where they found each other so why we
grew up in Cairo and he became
radicalized at a very young age as part
of a violent anti-government Islamist
movement he was a participant in a group
called the Islamic Jihad at Egypt he was
imprisoned by his account he was
tortured he was forced ultimately into
eggs
when he ended up in Afghanistan in the
late 1980s where he worked as a doctor
on the frontier helping wounded soldiers
in the war against the Soviets there he
met bin Laden who had arrived from a
much softer background than the whitened
and the wiry he was the son of course of
a construction billionaire he'd never
been imprisoned he had enjoyed quite a
lot of privilege and he had been
radicalized in university rather than in
prison and I over time as the two work
together they they shared a sense of
themselves as intellectuals I think as
elite within their own society in
comparison to a lot of the young men who
came to fight in Afghanistan who had
poor education and and no particular
sort of social background these two saw
themselves as compatriots in that
respect but then there was this
important difference which I think is
evident those you know there's a lot of
work left left to be done to figure out
exactly how their relationship work in
which the Egyptians tended to be much
more oriented toward terrorism strikes
towards operations they had a much
harder view of the world bin Laden was
more of a theorist a talker
a chairman of the board he got
interested in all of this and he seems
to have a rather you know sort of large
sense of himself but he had not gone out
and pulled the trigger and a lot of
operations the way the Egyptians have
done in this latest communication he
responds specifically to points made
about about about Al Qaeda by President
Bush in the State of the Union address
what's your assessment of Al Qaeda's
political understanding of the United
States and of its ability to for one of
a better word push buttons here in
society well it's it's it's I don't
think it's very well developed it relies
primarily on the media neither of these
men has spent significant amounts of
time in the United States that maybe
that's a wiry traveled in the United
States a little bit to raise money in
the in the 80s but even so he doesn't
have a rich personal understanding of
the West or the United States and
certainly bin Laden does not at the same
time they're relatively sophisticated
men in the sense that they consume a lot
of media and they their understanding of
the United States I think is
you know mostly derived from from that
you know they don't have a great record
in some respects of understanding
American politics or how the Americans
were going to react or what American
capability might be but they do have a
very powerful understanding of how to
use the media to communicate both with
their enemy and with their followers and
they they have developed one of the most
sophisticated media operations in the in
the history of modern terrorism
Ashton Maryland for Steve Paul all right
good morning Susan our first-time caller
if I could just take it back to the WMD
issue I'm from a country where you need
to you know find out the facts first
when you make a decision and I am just
absolutely amazed at the naivety of so
many people that call into this show and
on the news programs that believe that
just because we haven't found the WMD
yet but they were not there i watch the
DCI broadcast yesterday and mr. tenet
said there are 14,000 boxes of
additional documents that hasn't gone
through yet obviously not all of them
are going to reveal any WMD issues but
I'm amazed at the instant success that
everybody is demanding now watch some of
the people in Congress yesterday inquire
of the DCI making statements that
obviously they were never there and so
on and I'm just amazed I mean why don't
we wait until we get the process
completed get all the facts up on the
table and then say whether they were
there or not most of these things that
were some previous calls earlier said
well you know I'm out vast amounts well
some of these restaurants will fit in
somebody's closet so you're not talking
about large buildings and large
facilities necessarily unless you were
talking about nukes in most of the WMDs
those things would fit in people's
closets and in the trunk of the cars
thank you sir
just call you and tackle it yeah I mean
I think that that's a fair argument it's
certainly one that's made by the DCI as
the caller points out and and you know
there there will investigations will
continue over the months ahead I think
at the same time by now as David Kay
said when
he finished the phase of his work as the
sort of chief investigator of the CIA in
this matter you would have expected to
find more than they found either in
terms of people testimony infrastructure
remnants of programs it doesn't mean
that there aren't more discoveries to be
made but quite a lot of what was
forecasted has been examined and it just
isn't there
next is Toronto Saul are you there
good morning when we talk about Islamic
terrorism I think people will kill to
recognize that there's actually two
threats one is extra and all that stays
Wommack terrorists themselves the other
one which I believe is actually in fact
more dangerous is internal it's the
ideology the collectivist you know
multiculturalist moral relativists but
that are so prevalent in in America and
in Canada that is actually in fact the
greater threat that we could take care
of Islamic terrorism in a very short
period of time if we actually had the
courage to deal with it
mr. Kaul yeah well I mean I think that's
an argument that I'll just let's stand
on its own terms
could you talk please about Pakistan and
its support perhaps at the highest
levels of government for some of the
activities of the Taliban well it's an
important part of this history and a
complicated one but you know the
Pakistani government did essentially
create and support the Taliban from
shortly after its birth until the period
immediately before September 11th when
it was seeking control over the entirety
of Afghanistan and it's you know you
might think from this distance that it's
that it's a mystery why would the
Pakistani government which after all is
run by generals who have a relatively
secular and sophisticated outlook
they're military men in the British
tradition they run a highly professional
army they they do not themselves live
particularly religious lives though
they're you know there may be sort of
personally faithful there they're not
trying to spread their faith in
political terms so why would they back
the Taliban and it's a it's a question I
think a lot of Pakistanis are asking
these days but isn't but essentially the
reason is that they they've see
themselves for some good reason in a in
an existential contest with India their
neighbor with whom they've fought three
wars from whom they were forcibly
separated at birth
amid terrible violence and India is so
much larger so much more powerful and
and has so much more potential as a
nation than Pakistan does that the
Pakistanis and particularly its army
struggles to figure out how do we
compete and unfortunately during the
early 90s in the aftermath of the
successful program against the Soviets
in Afghanistan the Pakistani army
concluded that the way to level the
field with India was to use Islam ik
radical terrorists to tie down there are
me to bleed Indian civilians to frighten
India to to basically level the field
and the Taliban was a part of that
regional strategy it really wasn't about
the United States it really wasn't about
religion it was about this existential
struggle with India next a question for
Sioux Falls from Bradford Pennsylvania
good morning Susan a mister call my
curiosity involves the briefings that
the FBI in a change in administration
what started probably a year before 9/11
they must have presented all the threats
why was no security alerted I mean this
is almost like previous failures like
the cold
nobody responsible or Bayreuth where all
these Marines were killed they had
mornings but why didn't they act on all
the terrorist evidence that mr. Tennant
now had thank you well I think that's a
fair question and there it goes to this
period as the Bush administration takes
office in the first months of 2001 and
the outgoing Clinton administration
after this long strange deadlocked
election centered in Florida is finally
preparing to hand off power to the Bush
administration and in the National
Security Council the Clintons National
Security Adviser the second term sandy
Berger and his chief counterterrorism
aide
richardclark organized for the incoming
Bush team a series of very pointed
presentations about the bin Laden threat
they they really went out of their way
to say to the incoming team hey look
this is gonna be the issue that you are
going to spend more time on than you
understand
it's the biggest security threat out
there and we've got a lot of stuff in
motion and here are the details so they
walk through all of that but the Bush
administration had its own agenda I
think there's a natural tendency in a
sharply divided partisan climate like
that one to sort of dismiss the
priorities of the last regime set your
own agenda and that's what they did they
focused on their own list of priorities
missile defense Iran Iraq China some
other cases and while they put the al
Qaeda review in motion it moved at a at
a very slow pace really relative to what
we now in retrospect to understand the
threat to have been Salt Lake City is
next yeah yeah I really interested in
your inner looking into the CIA I the
information Rights Act was passed first
so that the secret intelligence agencies
would have to tell us what they're doing
right after that they came out with the
truth serum and what they were doing
right exactly right after that they came
out with another information right back
saying they didn't have to tell us
international security for 40 plus 50
years now with was looking at Waco JFK
these others fascinations and things are
unexplained that our information that's
still not there for under national
security do you believe that people like
Jennifer Hoover and people in these
secret agencies use that national
security to cover up what type of
corruption are doing a big chaining with
Halliburton and and you know yes CIA
base corruption that's hidden by reasons
of national security
okay time we fight thank you sir a big
question aerosol yeah just to pull out
one little piece of it there's you know
there's an enduring question in the
United States one that we haven't really
solved in which I'm quite confident will
come up again over the next 10 or 15
years which is how do you account for a
secret service in a democratic open
society how do you hold it accountable
how do you not paralyze it through
accountability but on the other hand
ensure that that oversight is being
carried out in a responsible and
democratic and transparent way and you
know the pendulum on that swings has
swung back and forth over the last 20
years right now there's a there's a
presumption of a national need for
action and secrecy and that place is a
great burden on the intelligence
community I think because if if they
repeat the errors that that have
hamstrung them in the past by running
ahead of where the American people would
want them to be or where our oversight
would would pull them back then they're
going to end up undermining their own
mission and and I think they're as aware
of that as anybody the second part of
the installment the accept the excerpt
that your paper printed of your book
focused around Ahmed Shah Massoud who
became relatively well known in that
state I remember watching a 60 Minutes
profile with him what is the key part of
his story that people listening to this
should know about it well how much of
Massoud was the most charismatic the
most effective guerilla leader on the
ground in Afghanistan he has a long
history but I think the part that's most
relevant to this story is is the one
that that occurs in the late 1990s at
that time he was the only Afghan
commander who was really at war with bin
Laden and the Taliban he was himself
engaged in an existential struggle a
daily war with with bin Laden's troops
with his Chechen volunteers as Pakistani
volunteers and with the Taliban and
Massoud is a complicated figure but
essentially he is an Afghan nationalist
Islamic in his faith and outlook but not
a proselytizer tolerant prepared to work
in coalition's and he sought the United
States out as an ally in his own
struggle against bin Laden and the CIA
sought him out as a potential partner in
their efforts to capture or kill bin
Laden before he carried out another
terrorist strike so they attempted to
forge this partnership but the
partnership was constrained
fundamentally by a policy decision that
the United States government made in
these years 98 to 2001
which was that they didn't want to take
sides in the Afghan war they didn't want
to get involved
with Afghans and Afghan problems they
just wanted to get bin Laden and as one
of my foods intelligence aides put it to
me in remembering these frustrating
conversations with the CIA they said
that the CIA was asking them essentially
to capture the King on a chess board
without touching any other piece and in
fact many of the CIA officers who were
involved in this liaison agreed with
Massoud about this they wanted a much
broader and more sort of militarized
policy but in but in the Clinton cabinet
there was a sense that one this was not
going to work - they would just be
condemning more innocent Afghans to
their death and and and three they just
thought that Massoud forces were too
unruly that they had a history of human
rights abuses that they were involved in
opium smuggling and other problems and
they just weren't prepared to take the
risk of a full partnership Stafford
Springs Connecticut good morning good
morning do you think that Clinton
actually destroyed weapons of mass
destruction and a couple of quick
follow-up would a change in the head of
the CIA actually change any culture in
the CIA as far as career professionals
and whatnot and it's my understanding
that CIA had a charter for outside the
boundaries of the United States and the
FBI inside the United States so we see
them intermarried here just to take the
question about the DCI you know it's an
interesting question because of course
in American politics we always like to
personalize institutions as large and
complicated as the CIA so everything
becomes about the director and the
director this and the director that it's
obviously an important office
nonetheless and I think that it has
three functions that are most important
that only the director of central
intelligence can can really be
responsible for one is managing the
relationship between the CIA and the
president because alone among security
agencies the CIA depends on direct
presidential authority for most of the
risk-taking that it does and so the DCI
has to be the one who forges the
institution's can
the president earns his confidence and
works through all of these kinds of
problems the second thing that the DCI
does that nobody else can do is to deal
with Congress and congressional
oversight to be responsive to keep
Congress informed but also to win
support from Congress which controls the
agency's budget and then the third thing
which the caller refers to is the thing
that any leader in a large organization
does which is to set sort of a broad
kind of culture or values priorities
make some tough decisions when only only
the leader can make them but but
essentially it's a it's a an institution
that is much bigger than its than its
leader next phone call for you mr.
crawle we have just a couple minutes
left is from McDonough Georgia yes
McDonough Georgia around a lot of bases
I guess you would say fourths and I've
talked to a lot of people coming back
from Iraq and they told me that their
main domain Gorgas or objective was they
didn't give me go into too much detail
but it's only basically they were
guarding well the world oil rigs I guess
you'd call and I just don't get how
American people can't draw a conclusion
that I mean you see Condoleezza Rice
with Chevron and Dick Cheney with
Halliburton the whole Bush family with
oil I don't get where people can't draw
a conclusion to see that this war was
about something else and now whether
it's a mass destruction okay thanks that
takes us in a different direction I'm
going to take a call from Columbus Ohio
yeah thank you for taking my call money
that uh you talked about Massoud and and
you know like they were they you know
the atrocity that they did the Taliban
also did the same thing so they had that
fashion world here but the thing is is
what I like to say doing uh the
beginning of the Bush era we also had
problems with China when uh you know the
the the plane spy plane was uh
and that took up some time also you know
doing the bush you know the beginning of
the right right sorry so you're arguing
that the administration was distracted
at a key time yeah and the she's right
to mention that China spy playing
episode that was one of the distractions
in the spring on the subject of Masood
and human rights violations you know
it's sort of hard in a war as brutal and
long-running as the Afghan war was to
kind of keep a human rights scorecard
but I do think that it's a fair to say
in retrospect that the Taliban's
totalitarian vision and its violence and
its appetite for power was far more
egregious than then the violations
carried out by Massoud partners and
really it was rarely Massoud himself or
his men who were engaged in human rights
violations he was trying to construct a
coalition he had some pretty nasty
partners sometimes